[Musique]
vous êtes sur france 24 et vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'afrique à la une ce soir suspendu mais
pas sanctionné c'est la décision de la
cedeao sur le burkina faso quatre jours
après le coup d'état à l'issue du sommet
extraordinaire qu'a tenus l'organisation
de façon virtuelle ce vendredi une
décision attendue mais pas surprenante
en l'instance sous-régionale et décriée
elle demande la libération du président
kaboré se prononcera plus tard sur les
sanctions nous en avons parlé avec le
président de la commission de la cedeao
jean claude broult depuis abidjan
et on parlera de cette histoire à peine
croyable
il y a il a existé en
1994 il y a moins de 30 ans en france
près de la ville de nantes un parc
animalier où on présentait les africains
dans un village reconstitué à côté des
animaux avec la pleine coopération du
gouvernement ivoirien nous en parlons
avec françois tchernia un des auteurs du
documentaire le village de qui
raconte cette histoire
la coupe d'afrique des nations en
relâche côté sportif aujourd'hui nous
irons à garoua où côté économique ce
sont les artisans qui misait tour sur la
compétition après deux ans de marasme à
cause du coc vide
on ouvre ce journal par la décision de
la communauté des états de l'afrique de
l'ouest qui pour la troisième fois en 18
mois a dû se réunir afin de prendre des
mesures contre un pays suite à un coup
d'état militaire ce vendredi la cedeao a
décidé de suspendre le burkina faso sans
sanctionner et exigent la libération du
président élu or marc christian kaboré
on a interrogé plus tôt depuis abidjan
jean-claude cas si brou le président de
la commission de la cedeao oui
alors effectivement il se le sommet
extraordinaire des chefs d'état de la
cedeao qui s'est tenue aujourd'hui en
visioconférence a pris les décisions
importantes la première donc ces deux
condamné ce coup d'état parce qu'il est
contraire aux dispositions de notre
protocole sur la démocratie et la bonne
gouvernance donc en plus de la
condamnation il a été décidé par les
chefs d'état de suspendre le burkina
faso donc des instants des instances nom
de la cedeao alors c'est une évidemment
sanction minimale donc parce que c'est
le coude était apparu à seulement cinq
jours où il n'y a pas vraiment encore eu
de contact il a été demandé également de
libérer immédiatement et sans conditions
président roch marc christian kaboré et
tous les ministres qui ont été arrêtées
et éventuellement et puis pour avoir
plus d'informations plus d'éléments les
chefs d'état ont dissident wei immédiate
war 2 missions la première c'est une
délégation du comité des chefs
d'état-major de la cedeao qui sera à
ouagadougou des deux mers demain samedi
et donc il va rencontrer les nouvelles
autorités militaires à ouagadougou pour
faire un peu le point et évaluer la
situation sécuritaire en particulier
pour vous entendre on où on voulait
l'entendre un jour oui on vous entend
messieurs vous je suis désolé on est
pris par conçu le volet politique oui en
est le politique donc une mission de
conseil des ministres pour justement à
rencontrer galles les autorités de la
burkinabè pour échanger sur la situation
politique d'accord alors quand les eps
quand les sanctions elles sont
appliquées ou sont décidées elles sont
pas acceptés par les populations qui les
vivent comme une punition collective qui
affectent l'économie du pays je pense
évidemment au mali est ce un certain
vous le savez remettre en cause la
légitime même la légitimité de la cedeao
lorsqu elle sanctionne les putschistes
et ne dit rien par exemple sur les
tripes auteuil âge des constitutions
pour permettre à certains de vos
dirigeants de briguer un troisième
mandat à jeudi au hasard je pense à
votre pays comme la côte d'ivoire par
exemple que répondez vous à ceux qui
s'interrogent là dessus
alors sur l'extinction je crois comme je
le dis cdc progressif dans le cadre dans
le cas du mali puisque c'est de ça que
vous paraît il n'y avait pas de
sanctions lorsque nous sommes mis
d'accord avec le mali sur le programme
de la transition donc du 15 septembre
2020 lorsqu'on a is it à cor et à cri
jusqu'au 24 mai 2021 lors de 2ème couche
n'y ait pas de sanction nous avons
soutenu accompagner le mali dans le
programme de transition de monnaie à
tous les partenaires de le faire mais
c'est lorsque après le deuxième coup
d'état de 24 mai 2021 que le pays a
pratiquement changé de dynamique eydap
d'objectif en faisant un édit
contrairement que le programme des
élections prévues pour le 27 févr 2022
n'était pas possible n'allez pas être
atteints que on a d'abord averti on a
échangé on envoie des missions discuter
attirer l'attention sur les risques en
novembre lors du sommet extraordinaire
il a été encore indiqué attention s'il
n'y a pas de progrès dans la mise en
oeuvre du programme pour les aider la
transition pour les élections il va y
avoir des sanctions donc on avait déjà
informé le risque était là début
décembre est à 10 le 12 plus précisément
encore une fois on a deux demander de
faire des progrès rapidement parce que
il y avait trop de dérapages par rapport
au calendrier et averti que si au 31
décembre y avait pas d cision on allait
prendre des sanctions donc c'est pas
quelque chose qui a été sur ça n'a pas
été une surprise
la défiance à l'égard de la cedeao est
de plus en plus forte dans plusieurs
pays africains au burkina faso la
population qui soutient largement les
putschistes sont plutôt méfiant de
l'instance ouest africaine comme nous
l'expliquent notre correspondant kalidou
sy à ouagadougou
bien avant le sommet extraordinaire de
la cedeao sur la situation politique du
burkina faso qui a eu lieu ce vendredi
on peut dire que l'institution ouest
africaine n'était pas vraiment dans le
coeur des burkinabè d'ailleurs lors des
manifestations en soutien au nouveau
pouvoir militaire le lendemain du coup
d'état j'ai pu échanger avec des
burkinabè et pour la plus grande
majorité la cedeao a perdu toute sa
crédibilité
ils lui reprochent en somme son double
discours c'est à dire d'un côté on
sanctionne sévèrement des régime
putschiste comme le mali et la guinée
qui ont reçu le soutien de la majorité
de leur population d'ailleurs et c'est
assez cocasse c'est l ex président
burkinabè kaboré qui avait lu le
communiqué des sanctions contre le mali
et je peux vous dire que ça a très mal
été perçue ici d'un autre côté ils ne
comprennent pas la position passive sur
la question des manipulations de
constitution comme on a pu le voir en
côte d'ivoire ou en guinée en ce qui
concerne le pouvoir militaire au burkina
faso rappelons que lors de sa première
allocution publique à la télévision
nationale c'était jeudi soir le
lieutenant-colonel damiba président du
mouvement patriotique pour la sauvegarde
et la restauration a tenté de rassurer
la cedeao en déclarant que le pays
continuera de respecter ses engagements
internationaux et que le burkina faso a
plus que jamais besoin de ses
partenaires
face à présent cette histoire à peine
croyable figurez-vous qu'en 1994 il ya
moins de 30 ans on pouvait en france où
près de la ville de nantes visiter un
parc animalier et y voir des africains
dans un village reconstitué avec la
collaboration pleine et entière des
autorités ivoiriennes de l'époque on en
a parlé avec françois tchernia co
réalisateur du documentaire intitulé le
village de il nous explique
pourquoi ce village était un enjeu
humain compenser révolu depuis les
années quand les doors et humains déjà
dans la manière de présenter de
présenter les personnes c'est un
document dans la mesure aussi où ça fait
peu de cas de comment les personnes qui
sont montrés sont également reçu et
comment elles sont traitées donc je
crois qu'on trouve des normes
similitudes avec ce que vous pouvez
faire lors des expositions coloniales
dans les années 30 experts alors vous
montrer aussi que c'est la conjugaison
de l'appât du gain tout en bafouant les
droits sociaux les plus élémentaires qui
a amené plus ou moins à la création du
parc mais expliquez nous comment c'est
possible qu'en 1994 dont il ya moins de
30 ans je le disais un tel parc et puis
exister légalement j'allais dire en
toute légalité d'une certaine façon
alors le safari park quand il voit ses
portes en 92 c1 c'est un lieu qui peut
être créée parce qu'il ya là le conseil
régional de loire atlantique qui est
derrière tout ça et c'est donc un
endroit qui doit rapporter des sous donc
quand dany laurent chaque saison créer
une nouvelle attraction pour ramener un
peu plus de monde il doit à chaque fois
innové et pour parfaire un peu son
tableau de chasse en fantasme c'est de
recréer l'afrique alors unique donnant
chaque année cette part faire un peu le
tableau est une année cette année-là à 4
à 14 ils décident d'installer un village
ivoirien est donc c'est créer une
attraction supplémentaire pour pouvoir
amener plus de gens et ça se fait avec
la vallée effectivement de toutes les
administrations publiques qui
soutiennent pleinement le safari park en
loire atlantique
direction le cameroun où de nombreux
artisans souhaitez profiter de la coupe
d'afrique des nations pour se faire
connaître et vendre leurs produits à
garoua où se jouent des matches de la
can des artisans espère rattraper le
manque à gagner perdu à cause de la
crise du coc vide un reportage de nos
correspondants au cameroun tony manga et
stéphanois
de la maroquinerie du la décoration des
bijoux dans les dédales de ce marché at
ease annales de garoua où se déroulent
des matchs de la coupe d'afrique des
nations des milliers de produits locaux
ça peut coûter qu'on aime ce matelas ou
mater a flashé sur ces sondes elle
typique de la région du nord cameroun ce
supporters nigérians est en quête d'un
souvenir authentique soutenu acheter les
embarras de fabrication artisanale qui
est trop différent de notre poids
pour convaincre ses potentiels acheteurs
à quelques mètres de là à 12 vante les
mérites de ses produits comme chaque
jour depuis le début de la quinzaine
sur le comptoir de cet artisan calebasse
porte clés et autres objets décoratifs à
12 les a fabriquées à la main et les
vents aux rares visiteurs qui arrivent
dans le village
pour lui la compétition c'est le moment
ou jamais de faire des affaires
[Musique]
de la visite déjà moi mon but de venir
se déprend les contacts est de faire
connaître mon produit par
péter je vais trouver un bon partenaire
qui fait peut-être dans mon domaine
aussi après deux années marquées par le
cos vide et la baisse du nombre de
touristes dans la région les artisans de
garoua confejes attendait impatiemment
le début de la grande fête du football
africain
cette poussière a investi près de 500
euros à l'approché de l'événement pour
doubler sa production d'objets en argile
mais c'est important financement tarde à
porter ses fruits faute de clients
j'avais ferme avant que quelques pièces
de tout temps au temps même s'il a pas
beaucoup de visiteurs j'ai investi
environ 300 milles et
j'espère que je vais dire est plus avec
cette fan à quelques jours de la fin de
la can la course contre la montre aux
affaires se poursuit pour les 200
artisans de ce village
sur ces belles réalisations que nous
refermons ce journal de l'afrique merci
à tous ceux qui nous ont suivis
d'abidjan à paris de garoua à yaoundé en
passant par nantes rester avec nous car
l'actualité continue sur france 24
[Musique]